ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد الحرب في
اوكرانيا يبدو انها لم تعد مقتصره على
حدودها فاقد اثار سقوط صواريخ شرق بولاندا
بالقرب من الحدود مع اوكرانيا قلقا من
تداعيتها لكنها رديت الفعل الغربي
والروسيه كذلك وصفت بالهادئه رغم اعلان
الحكومه البولنديه رفع ظهوزيه الوحدات
العسكريه ووضعها في حاله التاهب القصوى
امين عام الناتو يستمر
الى ان الهجوم في بولندا كان متعمدا واكد
ان تحليلات الاوليه تشير الى ان الهجوم في
بولندا تم بصوارخه دفاعيه اوكرانيا رئيس
البولندي انجدوده قال انه ليست لديه ادله
دامغه حول مصدر الصواريخ التي سقطت في
بولندا مشيرا الى انه يتم التعامل مع
الامر بشكل هداف فيما ذكر مسؤولون
امريكيون ان صاروخ الذي ضرب بولندا تم
اطلاقه من قبل القوات الاكرانيه ردا على
صاروخ روسي لكريملين رحب بما اعتبره ضبط
النفس من جنب امريكا مشيدا بموقف بيضا
وناتو الذي اعتبره رصينا بشان حادثه
بولندا كما نفذت روسيا استهدف قوتها
لاهداف بولندا وقال تدفع روسيه ان الحديث
عن سقوط الصواريخ الروسيه في بولندا
استفزاز متعمد يدف لتصعيد النساء اما
الموقف الاوكراني جاء مغيرا فقد راى
الرئيس
بولندا تصعيدهم كبير وتهددوا للامن
العالمي وهي استدعي تحرك حلف شمال
الاطلسيه
تبين
الحظ من المحتمل جدا ان يكون احد الصواريخ
التي اطلقتها الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
قد سقط على اراضينا والارجح انه لم يكن
انفجارا للصاروخ نفسه لكن من المحتمل انه
كان انفجار للوقود المتبقي فيه ربما يكون
صاروخ اس 300 صنع في الاتحاد السوفياتي
وهو صاروخ قديم ولا يوجد دليل على انه
اطلق من الجانب الروسي
الناس الجيش انسان التحقيق في هذا الحديث
مستمر ونحن بحاجه الى انتظار النتائج ليس
لدينا ما يشير الى ان هذا كان نتيجته هجوم
متعمد وليس لدينا ما يشير الى ان روسيا
تستعد لعمليات عسكريه هجوم
على مسافه لا تزيد عن 35 كلم من الحدود
الاوكرانيه البولنديه
شؤون يستوى سته لقد قلنا ان الارهاب لا
يقتصر على حدود دولتنا فحسب بل انه يمتد
بالفعل الى اراضي مندوفا واليوم ضربت
صواريخ روسيه بولندا اراضي دوله خليفه
على الامن الجماعي هذا تصعيد كبير جدا
ويجب ان نتحرك
[موسيقى]
من روسيا اريد تاكيد ذلك بعد التحقيق
الكامل لكن حسب مسار الصاروخ من غير
المرجح ان يكون اطلق من روسيا لكننا سنرى
لاحقا
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من موسكوي لنا
سبونينا باحثه في شؤون السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه من كيافا الدكتور
المحضر الوطنيه للدراسات الاستراتيجيه من
وارسو وسيم ابو حسن رئيس تحرير موقع
بولندا بالعربي اهلا بكم ضيوف الكرام
واسمحوا لي في الواقعه ان ابدا من كيف معك
دكتور اليكساندر في متابعه لتصريحات رئيس
الاوكرانيه
الباص يقول بانه ان كانت بولندا ااه
متضرره الاولى من اسقاط هذه الصواريخ قال
رئيسها باننا ننتظر تحقيقات وبان الارجح
بانه صاروخ انفجر ولم يسقط بطريقه متعمده
وبان هذا الصاروخ هو من منظمه دفاع جوي 3
والكل يمتلكها في المنطقه في الواقع ولكن
الرئيس الينسكي يعيد ويكرر ويؤكد بان هذا
الصاروخ روسي وهذا الاستهداف متعمد هل هذا
واقع يتحدث عنه زمان سكي او هذا ما يريده
الرئيس الاوكراني او هذا مفبركه يقول
البعض لتحقيق تصعيد منشود في المنطقه
على اي حال يعني فهمم
من الجدير بالذكر انه همم الروسي همم
تستمر يعني في قصر البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
فهي مخالفه للقانون الدولي الاتفاقيات
جنيف يعني اكثر من بروتوكولوس على عدم
استماعنا سقوط الصواريخ في بولندا من
يتحمل المسؤوليه
كانت واسعه هناك تقريبا
من روسيا خلال هذه الاخيره من القصص
فمخاطر شديده من قبل الرؤوس ان هم يقترب
وليس له اول مره بالمناسبه من الحدود من
حدود بولندا بتعلم الحدود
يعني ويلعبون بالنار يعني من هذه همم
خلينا همم يعني نبقى مع سؤال حتى لا
الناحيه او لا نحيد على موضوع الحلقه همم
هل الصاروخان اللذان سقط على اراضي بولديه
هي صواريخ روسيه ام هي صواريخ من منظومه
الدفاع الجوي اوكرانيه
والجانب الاوكراني يقترح همم اجراء تحقيق
مشارك مع البولنديين مع النيته يعني
بالنسبه همم
يعني تبدا من الضرب يعني لانه حتى لو كان
همم الدفاع الجوي يعني شك انه هناك دفاع
جوي موجود لو لم يكن هناك الدفاع الجوي
الاوكراني فمتنا يعني من زمان
الى الدفاع عن انفسنا حتى ان كانت منظومه
دفاع روسيه ولكن روسيا تتحمل مسؤوليات
اسقاط الصواريخ على بولندا
مساء الخير كيف ممكن تتحمل المسؤوليه على
صواريخ اوكرانيه وقعت في بولندا ولو كانت
طائشه ولكن اهم شيء ان هي اوكرانيه
والجميع ايجار ذلك هناك تصريحات همم
مسؤولين غربي
الدرجه العالميه الان قد خفت همم لانه حتى
في بولندا عارف هو انه صواريخ من مضاداتته
اوكرانيه هم اخطاوا عليهم ان اعترفوا بهذا
الخطا ولكن همم حتى لو ابتعدنا عننا موضوع
همم
صواريخ
هذا الحادث برايه
لانه هو يشير الى درجه هناك خطوره الوضع
فاا اي حادث همم ممكن همم
الحرب العالميه الثالثه
والبعض حتى يرجع الى ان الموضوع متعمد
صيدا يريد هل تعتقدين بانه هذا الحادث
عرضي او هناك شبهه متعمده من وراء اطلاق
هذه الصواريخ
في اوكرانيا يوجد همم ناس
وهم لا يريدون التسويه الان هم يريدون
امدادات الاسلحه من الغرب بشكل اكثر وهم
يراهنون على التصعيد هم يحلمون
باضعاف روسيا بشكل كامل هذا خطا
ولكنني بهذه الحاله لا اعتقد ان الخطا من
قبل اوكرانيين كان متعمد همم انا همم
اتصور انه همم هذا الشيء كان خطا ولكن حتى
في حاله الخطا عليهم ان يعترفوا بهذا
الشيء ان يقدمه همم
بولندا وان يوضح هذا الامر لتخفيف التوتر
هذا في افضل السيناريوهات ان يكون هذا
حادث عرضي ولكن البعض الاخر استاذ وسيم
يطرح امكانيه تعلم حضرتك هناك من يؤمن
بفرضيه المؤامره وانا هناك مؤامره وانا
هناك ذلك حتى من يريد الايقاع ببولندا
واقحامها الى هذا الصراع بولندا العضو في
حلف انه اقامه في الصراع يعني اقحام
الناتو هل تعتقد بانه هناك تعمد من وراء
همم هذا الاسقاط لهذه الصواريخ وان كان
عمان المستفيد الاول
يعني تعاطي الحكومه البولنديه كانت مع
الازمه مثل اللحظه الاولى تعاطي منطقي جدا
لم يتم توجيه اي اتهامات في جميع البيانات
التي اصدرتها الحكومه كانت بيانات مقتضربه
اشاره الى وقوع ضحايا فقط ولم تشعر الى
الجهه التي تم اسقاطها حتى عندما بدا
التحقيق في الموضوع تم الاشاره الى انه
صاروخ روسي الصنع ولم يقل ان روسيا هي
التي اسهمت في همم او هي التي قامت باطلاق
هذه الصواريخ
وفي مواجهه مباشره مع الجانب الروسي هذا
مواقع بالفعل
حتى دخل حلف الناتو يعني لكل متابع
للشهاده الاخراني يعلم بان هناك ايضا
خلافات داخل حلف ان حتى نفسه في همم طريقه
التعاطي مع الجانب الروسي وكيفيه اجباره
على الدخول في مفاوضات سواء برفع سقف
العقوبات او زياده الدعم العسكري او محطه
الدعم السياسي للجانب الاوكراني لكن بشكل
كما قلنا يعني التعاطي كان التعاطي
البولندي كانت تعاطي ايجابي وحيادي حتى
اللحظه كما قلنا حتى اللحظه لم تنتهي
تحقيقات ستقوم بها
لوحدها ام ستكون هناك جهات تتشارك معها في
هذه التحقيقات همم والوقت خاصه بعد كم وقت
سنتمكن من متابعه نتائج
التحالفته طبعا الحلف الناتجه موجود في
المنطقه ايضا المنطقه التي تم استهدافها
لا تبعد كثيرا عن احد القواعد الامريكيه
الموجوده في المنطقه في المنطقه
الامريكيه
لا يوجد جدول زمن حتى اللحظه للموضوع لكن
جميع الفرق وتواجد على ارض الواقع وتم
تامين المكان وجمع الحصان والتدريب حاليا
دراسه الموضوع لتقديم تقرير كامل سواء كان
للمجتمع البولندي الذي يظهر حتى اللحظه
يعني تحت صدمه كبيره من ما حصل لشركاء
بولندا والولايات المتحده وغيرها من
الاصدقاء
المقربين من الموبايل
نحن في الواقعه في متابعتنا لهذه العمليه
هناك قراءه البعض يقول بانه هذه المرحله
هي مرحله ليس تقارب ليست موده ولكن على
الاقل محاوله
لايجاد حلول هذا اطرحوه الغرب سواء واشنطن
او حتى اوروبا وروسيا تقبل بالمفاوضات
الغير قابل بالمفاوضات هو الجانب الاخراني
واوكراني من مصلحتها ان تصاعد وان تقحم
اطرافا اخرى همم على الاقل حتى همم لا
تعود خطوه الى الوراء هل هذا ما يريده
زلاكي
الاوكرانيين الموجودين حاليا في الاراضي
المحتله الذين يتعرضون لتعذيب باستمرار
يعني الى المطارده من قبل
المخابرات الروسيه يعني فهناك همم فانتم
يعني هناك في كل مكان لا يتحرر من من
الروس يعني مثل همم
هناك من قاعده جماعيه هناك همم اشياء يعني
بصراحه همم
قبيح جدا يعني يعني الناس يعني يعانون من
الاحتلال الروسي
الرئيس كذلك همم اهم شيء بالنسبه لنا كلنا
همم يعني الدفاع عن الاراضي الاوكرانيه عن
الناس
بالدارجه الرئيسيه فعلشان ذلك
فنحتاج فعلا الى الاصلحه وهناك همم يعني
دعم يعني ماده من قبل الغربيين الذين هو
يعني همم
لو سمحت لي ولكن حتى موضوع الدعم يناقش
اليوم داخل نيته همم
والبعض يقول بانزكيل لم تتبقى له خيارات
غير انه الموضوع يصبح شامل لدوله همم تتبع
الناتو دوله اخرى يعني يمكن ان تكون معنيه
بالموضوع ومن هنا اتت الصعيد في بولندا هل
هذه القراءه يمكن ان تكون صحيحه و دقيقه
محاوله لفهم يعني وبصراحه اي شيء واضح
كذلك ان روسيا هي تخاطر يعني حتى في همم
بسلامه الدول المجاوه لان هي همم تعرض
ليست فقط القران يعني لكن حتى المناطق
القريبه جدا من الحدود يعني فهي مصدر خطر
وليس فقط لاوكرانيا واللي اوروبا
هل انتم مصدر خطر ليس فقط على اوكرانيا
ولكن حتى على الدول الحدوديه
طيب صواريخ اوكرانيه وقعت في بولندا فااا
فلماذا الحديث عن خطر من روسيا
والكلام من قبل ضيف اخر انه
صواريخ اوكرانيه ولكنها صناعه روسيه فا
ايضا غريب جدا برايه همم هذا الحادث قال
له هو متعمد ام لا همم لكي نعم هو متزامن
مع قمه 20 وهذا صحيح يثير تساؤلات كثيره
ولكنني اعتقد على كل ان همم
اوكرانيين لم يصل
هذا النوع همم من
المؤامرات همم
اعتقد انه على كلا صواريخ
لكن همم اذا كان احد في القران او في
بولندا او في دول بلطوق يعتقد بانه مثل
هذا الحادث ممكن ان يؤدي الى ده همم اسلحه
بشكل اكثر لاوكرانيا انا اعتقد بالعكس
هناك دول مثل فرنسا والمانيا وحتى امريكا
حتى امريكا رغم انها مصلحتها اطاله هذه
المواجهه ولكن همم لا تريد ان تكون هناك
الحرب على العالميه الثالثه فهم الان
فهموا انه اي حادث مثل هذا ممكن ان يؤدي
لتوسيع دائره المواجهه بشكل خطير للجميع
همم اعتقد انه من وراء هذا الحادث بالعكس
ممكن ان يكون ان يحدث تكسيف اتصالات
الدبلوماسيه سريه وغير سريه ما بين روسيا
ودول للغرب وحتى رئيس بولندا اليوم في نفس
هذا الاتجاه سيد وسيم رئيس بولندا الذي
شفناه في اول هذه الازمه يتحدث بتشنج
وكانت هناك حتى تسريبات عن انا بولندا
قادره ان تساعد اوكرانيا وتمد لها اسلحه
متطوره هجوميه بحسب التسريبات لم تتحقق
حتى الان ولكن اليوم شاهدناه وهو متاسف
وهو يتكلم وكانه يمحو الى تهدئه هل هناك
تغير في موقف بولندا هل هناك تغير تقراه
في الموقف الاوروبي عموما
نعم موقف الرئيس الحلم البولندي وايضا
الحكومه البولنديه كان يعني موقفا الى
شقين الشقه الخارجي وهو التعاطي مع ما حدث
سياسيا دبلوماسيا خصوصا مع مع حلفاء
بولندا وحلفاء ورثه في حلف الناتو
والناحيه الاخرى هي التوجه للمجتمع
البولندي الذي كان مدعور بالحقيقه بشكل
كامل مما حدث للمره الاولى تتجاوز
الصواريخ الروسيه الحدود البولنديه وتسقط
داخل اراضيها في دوله اساسا عانت في خلال
الحرب العالميه ولا يزال شبح الحرب
العالميه مخيم على مخيله البولنديين
فطريق التعاطي الحكومه كانت بطريقه
العاطفيه نوعا ما كانت موجهه للداخل وليست
للخارج المواجهه بين بولندا وروسيا يعني
وحتى وانت تجاوزنا موضوع الصاروخان
متواجده حاليا على اكثر من اليوم الحديث
عن تسليح جايب كانكراد الحرب الهيدروجين
التي تستخدمها روسيا ضد هولندا بارسال
المهاجرين الى الحدود بس اهداف خاصه
انابيب نورت ستريم
العديد من الملفات يمكن
واشرحقيقيه بين جميع الاطراف لياتي بعدها
وصول هزار الصاروخين الى الاراضي
البولنديه فال- كما قلنا لم تتهم الحكومه
البولنديه الجانب الروسي باطلاق هذه
الصواريخ حتى في بدايه الموضوع لكن اي
متابعه الموضوع كان اللحظه الاولى سيشك او
سيوفجي اصابع الاتهام الى روسيا التي كما
قلنا يوجد عده ملفات تتواجد فيها مع
بولندا همم
من غير المتوقع ان تقوم بولندا بتغيب
لهجتها على الاغلب انها ستزيد من كميه
المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا واستمرار
الضغط السياسي همم الاستمرار سياستها
والخلافات التاريخيه الموجوده
الى تصريحات سيد همم
وتعليقه كذلك على تصريح البيت الابيض همم
الذي يؤكد بان روسيا تتحمل المسؤوليه في
النهايه عن الصاروخ التي ضرب بولاندا يعني
همم روسيا اسقطته او همم روسيا همم امم هي
التي همم
تسببت في دفع اوكرانيا بالدفاع عن نفسها
باطلاق صواريخ دفاعيه في روسيا هي همم
التي تستحمل المسؤوليه هل يمكن ان يحمل
المجتمع الدول المسؤوليه لروسيا في هذا
التوقيت وما اهميه ذلك
نحن نتكلم ليس عن المجتمع الدولي ان نتكلم
عن امريكا وحلفاء همم
توجه امريكا هو معادله روسيا ولكن في نفس
الوقت همم اتصل على حتى هي بدات وهي الان
همم
ممكن ان تتكرر حسب ما اعرف قنوات الاتصال
ما بين امريكا وروسيا لم تتقطع خلال
فتره المواجهه كلها دليل انه في شهر ابريل
تم هناك تبادل سجناء امريكي
على مستوى المخابرات الثنائيه الروسيه
الامريكيه سوف تحتظرها
هي حدثت الان ولكن
ان تحدث صفقه ما حول تبادل السجناء مره
اخرى
وهذا اذا حدث هذا يشير الى انه العلاقات
على كل باقي ما بين القنوات الاتصال ما
بيننا
وامريكا بالاضافه الى المحادثات حول
معاهده ستارت حول عدد رؤوس نوويه
والصواريخ
وزيارات المراقبه على ما يحدث في هذا
المجال همم
فانا براي همم كل هذا يدل على انه هناك
قوه سياسيه تريد ان تبحث عن حل سياسي لهذه
المواجهه المشكله في موقف اوكرانيا وهو ما
زال صاله المشكله فيكم دكتوره الكسندر
يعني المشكله في الروس يعني شوف الحقيقه
ان روسيا هي الدول المعتدئه المعروفه على
مين وحتى على مستوى الامم المتحده
يعني العدوان ضد
الدوله فكل العواقب على روسيا وليس على
الجامع
[موسيقى]
باجرام الحربي في كل مكان
كل مناطق المحتله وكذلك هم الى حد الان
يعني يتكلموا على نفسه طيب
الحلقه ولكن اكيد باننا سنبقى في متابعه
تداعيات عمليات اسقاط هذه الصواريخ ساعتذر
منكم ساكتفي بهذا القدر على ان اراكم
والقاكم في حلقات اخرى من موسكو الينا
الباحثه في شؤون السياسيه
ابو حصار رئيس تحرير موقع بولندا بالعربي
شكرا جزيلا على المشاركه ولا نقاش دائما
السلام عليكم